jean pierre murat connaissait-il
christelle malric il est accusé d'avoir
tué de 30 coups de couteaux s'étaient en
86 au creusot questions posées au
quatrième jour de son procès en appel à
dijon où nous retrouvons en direct elle
a besoin pour tenter de répondre à cette
question des membres de la famille de la
victime et de l'accusé était appelé à
témoigner à l'époque des faits j'étais
une petite fille j'avais 9 ans très émue
delphine pis on évoque cette sorte
disparu tragiquement christelle une
adolescente joyeuse et pleine de vie si
au cours du premier procès c'est un
besoin pour moi d'exprimer tout ce que
j'avais exprimé à l'époque je n'ai
jamais pu exprimer toute la douleur que
cela suscite et pour me construire
aujourd'hui c'était vraiment pour faire
apparaître christelle au procès montre
et c'était notre soeur qui devrait être
là aujourd'hui
les souvenirs de christelle contre
l'amnésie des murs à à la barre joseph
le grand frère de jean pierre murat
revient sur ses déclarations passées
il dit avoir oublié ses excès de
violence et cette obsession pour la
faire on sentiment sur mon frère est
innocent est totalement innocent du
meurtre de christelle malgré les
policiers ont fait leur travail ils ont
déjà trouvé un coupable mais un coupable
idéal qu'ils ont trouvé quelqu'un de
malade qui souffre de schizophrénie et
qui étaient sous traitement et
alcoolique joseph murat qui semble avoir
voulu épargner son frère s'était
exprimée très largement à la première
cour d'assises en première instance et
là il a vraiment tout oublié
vraiment vraiment et la présidente
laborieusement arrive à nous faire
sortir de phrase je crois que la
condamnation de son frère est passé par
là l'indignation qui n'a manifesté à
cette condamnation est donc il a décidé
de se taire demain l'audience va se
poursuivre avec l'audition des amis et
de l'ancienne compagne de jean pierre
murat des témoignages qui avaient été
accablant l'an passé notamment sur la
santé de l'accusé
procès à suivre également sur le site
internet de france 3 bourgogne